autorisation de taguer à Manille les
c'était samedi dernier lors du festival
annuel de cultures urbaines au programme
activité atelier animation spectacle et
[Musique]
battle juste pour l'esprit découverte
voilà sans prise de
tête show business ou quoi que ce
soit face à lui lors de la demi-finale
de break un danseur expérimenté entraîné
pour les défis
je regarde un peu plus quand même le
côté États-Unis parce que c'est de la
bxavent faut pas l'oublier l' poop c'est
une culture assez ouverte on va chercher
un peu de partout les arts martiaux la
capera la gymnastique selon le B boy
l'âge d'or de cet art de rue en France
c'était vers 98 99 depuis les styles et
même les public ont
changé je suis content et j'apprécie
avec mes filles ma femme tranquillement
nous c'est la première fois qu'on
participe et c'est très très intéressant
voilà il y en a pour tous les âges tous
les goûts et ça ça vraiment ça ouvre
l'esprit à plusieurs
cultures le public vote pour son danseur
favori à l'aide de carton coloré mais la
décision finale revient au jury composé
de personnel de la Ville et de
professionnels du milieu on nous a donné
une feuille avec certains critères de
technicité de performance de il a
différentes choses
mais c'est c'est très difficile de
mettre les choses aussi clairement dans
des
cases à la clé pour le meilleur une
dotation de 200 € offerte par la commune
de manilé
[Musique]
Amou